[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here so one of the
most common problematic areas that we
women get really self-conscious about is
our muffin top and also love handles so
I've designed this workout to really
focus on the side apps and you will be
doing lots of twisting motion to really
target the core and also to tighten this
midsection it's going to be a
combination of ab exercises and also
cardio to elevate your heart rate and
burn this fat layer up basically your
total body as well so there will be
eight exercises okay each workout will
be for 30 seconds long with 15 seconds
rest in between and the goal is to
complete two rounds so get your body
warmed up and let's do this workout
together grab a mat and we want to be
working on our mat so there will be lots
of crunches to begin with lie down on
your mat okay I went in to just bend
your knees keep your huge closed earbud
and the first workout will be a crunch
and also cross punch okay so we're going
to upper abs crunch up punch good hands
by your side crunch up punch very nice
only thirty Seconds punch and twist it's
all about the twisting motion good nice
strong punches okay not those soft
punches
twist move your waist move your hips
twist keep going we'll work on your
upper abs and work on your obliques do
more and rest it out second workout
bicycle crunches so still on your mat
lie down okay hands by your ears
beginners you can just twist put your
feet on the floor
twist and rest for those of you who
wants to challenge yourself
legs up twist and alternate good keep
going work on your oblique muscles keep
twisting look the opposite side don't
rest your head on the floor okay
lift your shoulders off the floor good
feel the side of your apps Bernie
last few more keep twisting nice and
controlled movement okay and now get up
get into a plank and the next move it's
going to be breakdancer okay so in a
tool play and just twist and open the
opposite side that's it okay twist and
open ready
show me your break dancer move if you
want to you can even add a little bit of
hop and twist and open up good keep
going twist open twist and pick
so it's all about moving those hips and
also moving your waist good control and
nice movement okay
few more last three seconds and just
rest it out a little bit again onto your
plank
we want to do cross knee tucks to
Frogger again ready play cross knee
tucks and hop ready let's go cross blue
tux and pop release good back knee tucks
hop release very nice beginners what you
can do is take a step in and release
step back cross pop release nice hot
back cross hop few more really work on
twisting
remember all the exercises the goal is
to twist now let's get down next plank
hip dip okay so get into a low plank and
just twist your waist from side to side
breathe deeply
pace your breathing okay let's go deep
side to side so maintain a solid
straight plank position
just dip to the left and to the right do
not like too high up okay this is wrong
keep it straight leveled and just dip to
your left
and to your right very good dip work on
twisting those hips work on twisting
those waist five more seconds
nice one more and take a shot breather
15 seconds rest now let's move on to the
side plank crunch so get onto your side
my sweat is dripping
bend your knees okay straighten the top
leg and crunch touch crunch touch okay
crunch and tap gently crunch and tap
that's it let's just work on one side
for this set for the second round we
will work on the other side so really
crunch and feel this part working good
crunch tap crunch and tap very nice keep
going five more seconds tap good keep
going and now just rest it up now let's
get into a high plank and I just want
you to twist open up alternate twist and
open up okay it is that simple so ready
three seconds and let's go twist and
open up twist and open up again keep
your plank strong and high okay remember
it's all about working on your core
strength good twist and open twist and
open look the opposite side twist and
open keep going open twist and open few
more twist open twist good keep going
you're almost there and just rest it out
one last workout it's going to really
work on your core bunnyhop left to right
start in a high plank position again
okay three more seconds ready and now
let's hop left center right center left
good that's it this is a cardio based
workout to bring your heart rate back up
very good guys kick those arms and show
the strong
keep your core strong do your heart rate
pumping gonna stop right now you have
ten seconds and you will get a
one-minute break keep going
last few are give me two more hops one
more ah
oh my god well done
take a short break wipe your sweat keep
it up hydrated and we want to do the
second set ha get into a child's pose
[Music]
okay so you have 20 seconds left okay
it's the second set you know all the
workouts so I want you to give me your
best effort let's lie down and let's
start with cross punch okay
bend your knees heels close to your butt
ready give me a nice strong cross punch
ready crunch it up and twist left to
right good push through okay it's a
second set stay strong you might be
sweaty you might feel heart rate pumping
but that's what we want up and punch
good lie down up and cross punch strong
punches okay every movement is as
important work on your upper abs and you
give me a nice good solid crunch and
just rest it out next workout will be
bicycle crunches okay so leg straight
remember it's all about a twisting
motion all right hands by your ears
ready lift both legs up and let's go
twist twist and twist good so open up
twist as far as you can and reach very
nice rich oh good
elbow to knee elbow to your knee good
open your chest up keep a chest open
lift your shoulders off the floor
I remember pace your breathing
last one and rest it up get up your
favorite move breakdancer to get into a
plank okay remember it's all about
twisting I want to see your breakdancing
moves
ready three seconds and let's go open up
open whoops
open I'll twist I got too excited open
and twist get messy hair that's what we
want
sweaty face good if you want to add a
little bit of hop remember it will still
look cute at the end of your workout you
did not train hard enough so I want to
see those sweaty face and palms keep
going
last one oh and now take a shot 15
seconds rest back into plank and we want
to do cross and knee tucks to progress
okay five seconds high plank
strong plank let's go cross and jump and
release back cross hop release good
strong solid plank okay move those hips
move your waist twist your waist do your
entire body working hop and release back
hop and release good twist whoa few more
hop and rap it out a lot of playing
exercises I know I love to workout
because you really target the entire
core and also the deeper core so let's
get into a low plank I like to do plank
hip deep let's go left to right left to
right good see your sweat dripping on
the floor on the mat that's what I want
you to feel that intensity and that
satisfaction right at the end of the
workout breathe okay into your nose out
through your mouth
ten seconds keep dipping nice left to
right left to right controlled movement
very good few more
yes side plank now let's work on the
other side okay so opposite side
remember
bottom leg keep it that public straight
and we want to crunch and tap ok good
crunch and tap oh my god
sweat is coming into my eyes crunch and
tap so really work on this part crunch
tap crunch and tap very good
remember don't drop your hips lift it up
crunch and tap crunch and tap very nice
lift your hips up okay maintain a nice
side plank five more seconds last few
more last one and press it out back into
a high plank okay you know the workout
what is it
it is plank twists so five more seconds
ready give me a high solid play and
let's go open up open and twist yeah I
know you are sweaty but you know what
you only have one workout left after
this okay we want to finish with a
strong cardio so take this time to
really breathe breathe and twist
remember don't pick your butt up or arch
your lower back straight plank last four
more seconds last twist and just take a
shot ten seconds breather breathe in
it's a breathing last side hop bunny
twist okay well let's go high plank in
two one
let's go left center right center
good okay find your rhythm twist find
your rhythm don't break your rhythm find
your rhythm keep your upper body strong
and keep hopping this is your final
workout don't stop now
push through because you are done right
after this come on last five seconds no
don't drop now give it two more
last one oh and rest get into a child's
pose drink some water
look at me so sweat this so drench but
I'm satisfied so let's just stretch it
out Oh guys I am drenched in sweat
that's the whole point of this workout I
want you to be drenched in sweat so I've
done two sets if you're feeling strong
if you want to challenge yourself even
more then go ahead and complete three
sets do this workout at least three to
four times weekly the best results you
can do this workout right at the end of
a total body workout to just give you
that burst of energy okay don't forget
to like this video share this video keep
this workout consistent and trust me you
will see a huge difference on your body
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more crazy sweaty workout and do
also turn on your notification button so
that you will get notified every time I
upload a workout video recipes or even a
workout challenge all the best you got
it